no risk no reward right but that's what
happens on a major Network risks
Millions on a show about musical cops
developed by Lana and Lily Wachowski
along with Babylon 5 Creator J Michael
strasinski since a premiered on Netflix
in 2015. the show follows a group of
people from around the world who
inexplicably gain the ability to
psychically link with each other before
they know it they're being menaced by a
secret organization apparently led by an
enigmatic individual known as Whispers
since age received positive reviews from
both critics and viewers and won a
number of awards but that didn't stop
Netflix from canceling the show at the
end of season two an outcry from fans
led to the streaming giant producing a
final two and a half hour long finale to
tie up the story and ensure it didn't
end on a cliffhanger variety reported
that Ted sarando's Chief content officer
for Netflix at the time confirmed the
show was simply proving to be too
expensive considering its small audience
more the company doesn't generally
release information about budgets and
viewing figures the fact that it costs
around 9 million dollars per episode was
seemingly too much for Netflix to
justify most of that cast came down to
the long production time and the fact
that it was filmed on location around
the world
Netflix is no stranger to canceling
high-profile shows if they don't live up
to the company's expectations which
could mean they haven't managed to
attract enough viewers it shouldn't come
as a huge surprise that the get down was
axed after just a single season despite
rave reviews and numerous Award
nominations created by director baz
luhrmann and Pulitzer prize-winning
playwright Stephen adley gerges the 2016
musical drama focuses on a group of
teenagers living in the South Bronx of
New York during the 1970s Netflix
announced that the get down would not be
returning to the streaming service in
2017. having already cut down the first
season from 13 episodes to 11. this was
largely a result of costly production
delays and the mid-season departure of
showrunner Sean Ryan according to
variety research suggested that the show
received just a fraction of the viewers
as other Netflix originals and interests
appeared to drop off quickly considering
the first season apparently costs around
120 million dollars in its Little Wonder
that Netflix did not want to come it to
more episodes
would you think you're just gonna keep
running this thing without my knowledge
information regarding the mountainous
trunk of facility has always been on a
the event is an NBC sci-fi thriller
series a first hit television screens in
2010 and ran for a single season before
it was in ceremoniously shelved after
just 22 Episodes the story focuses on a
group of extraterrestrials who crash
land on Earth in a remote region of
Alaska during World War II those on
board the unidentified crafter taken
prisoner and held in captivity by the
United States although many survivors of
Aid capture managed to hide among the
human population when a new president
takes office he plans to free the aliens
and reveal their existence to the world
bertis quickly called turbine an
assassination attempt even though the
event had a strong start when it was
first broadcast it quickly began to lose
viewers the series also failed to
impress critics making it a likely
Contender for cancellation while an
exact budget has never been revealed The
Hollywood Reporter indicated that NBC
spent at least 10 million dollars
marketing the event suggesting that it
was a big budget undertaking
and most people think of their fugitive
they'd likely picture the 1993 film
starring Harrison Ford and Tommy Lee
Jones Dr Richard Kimble is framed for
the murder of his wife and sentenced to
death for killing her he's inadvertently
freed however while being transported to
prison and sets out to find the actual
culprit while being pursued by U.S
Marshals there will be multiple versions
of the story over the years dating back
to the original 1960s television series
in 2000 CBS launched a remake of the
earlier show also titled The Fugitive
with Tim Daly portraying Kimball and
Michael T Williamson as a U.S Marshal
trying to apprehend him in canceled
after one season ending on a cliffhanger
the Post-Gazette reported that the pilot
alone cost an estimated 6 million
dollars to produce a rather large figure
for two thousand according to the
Hollywood Reporter drama Pilots cost 5
million dollars on average in 2007
suggesting that The Fugitive was
certainly on the high scale for a
television series
although it is not part of the official
Canon of the Star Wars Universe the Star
Wars holiday special came out not long
after the first film and is set between
a New Hope and The Empire Strikes Back
It Centers on Chewbacca and Han Solo's
attempt to visit the planet kashyyk or
being pursued by Imperial forces and
Bounty Hunter Boba Fett the one million
dollar budget which was around 10
percent of the total cost of a new hope
is equivalent to more than 4.5 million
dollars today so the special was
certainly inexpensive production the
show was universally panned by almost
everyone who has seen it even those who
worked on the project including cast
members such as Mark Hamill Carrie
Fisher and Harrison Ford have been
critical of the project and how it
turned out do you remember making this
Christmas special I think it was 1978
no you don't remember it
Star Wars Creator and director George
Lucas has even remarked that he wants to
destroy every copy of the special that
is still available
starring Natalie Martinez Kate Bosworth
Kyle Schmidt and Sevilla Dean the island
is a Netflix sci-fi thriller that tracks
10 strangers who wake up on a beach
without any idea how they got there or
knowledge about their own identities
conflict soon breaks out and it is later
revealed that this is a digital
simulation meant to test whether violent
criminals will return to the way they
once behaved under all new circumstances
after his Premiere the island was
universally criticized its holds a
critics rating of just eight percent on
Rotten Tomatoes and a similarly bad
audience score suggesting that very few
people enjoyed anything about it in this
review of the series Pace criticized his
absurdity and called it an embarrassment
the writer stated I have watched some
truly truly Bad series in my day but few
that went off the rails this hard this
fast considering that the island cost
approximately 14 million dollars for a
limited series of just 7 40 minutes
episodes few could argue this was a good
investment
2018's Troy fall of a city was a
co-production with Netflix and the BBC
said during the mythological age of
ancient Greece the show charts a Trojan
Invasion after Paris played by Louis
Hunter fleece Sparta with Bella Danes
Helen of Troy this prompts a war between
the two Nations as Achilles and the
other Greeks attempt to take back Helen
despite positive reviews Troy fall of a
city mostly failed to attract viewers
and managed just 3.2 million audience
members for its opening episode almost 2
million less than a typical Saturday
evening Primetime slot a few episodes
later this number had dropped to just
1.6 million in total a dramatic fall for
an expensive show according to the times
the series costs almost 2.5 million
dollars an episode putting here to the
total cost of 20 million dollars for its
eight episode first season this made it
one of the BBC's most expensive dramas
ever made
an adaptation of channel 4's 2013 series
of the same name Utopia is a 2020 Amazon
Prime video series that was created by
gun girl writer Gillian Flynn starring
John Cusack Rayne Wilson Sasha Lane and
Desmond Borges the premise of the show
is that a group of younger dolls
discover a cult comic book and become
aware of its connection to a vast Global
conspiracy armed with this knowledge
they set out to save the world but also
become targets for a secretive
underground organization Amazon canceled
the series after a single eight episode
season Utopia was originally said to be
produced by HBO but the show was shelved
following a dispute over the budget
according to rumors reported by deadline
director David Fincher wanted more than
100 million dollars to shoot the series
but Executives at HBO were unwilling to
offer more than 95 million dollars
although the series found a new home
with Amazon in light of covet 19's
all-encompassing impact on the real
world of 2020 it's safe to say the TV
viewing public of the era where she
uniquely disinterested in an Escapist
sci-fi fantasy program about a deadly
Global pandemic
cop Rock was created by Stephen bochko
the man responsible for the hit crime
drama Hill Street Blues but cop Rock
takes the concept of a typical police
procedural and blends in musical
elements as the various detectives and
police officers in the LAPD carry out
their work a number of choreographed
musical numbers push the story forward
and provide extra context to viewers
it's going to be singing and dancing
about police yeah about police that's a
highly experimental concept cop Rock was
always likely to face an uphill battle
and the show was canceled after just 11
episodes of the planned 13 that were due
to make up season 1. reports from the
time suggest that the series failed to
attract a large enough audience and had
average reviews The New York Times
revealed that cop rock also had a large
budget roughly 40 percent larger than
equivalent shows in its time slots and
was costing more than one million
dollars per week
the Playboy club is a 2011 NBC series
set during the 1960s that follows the
action around the first Playboy club in
Chicago the show Stars Eddie cyprian a
shady lawyer Nick Dalton and Amber Heard
as a new employee at the club with a
closet full of skeletons controversial
from the moment that it first hit
television screens the Playboy club did
not prove to be a hit with critics or
viewers a series struggled in the
ratings losing millions of viewers
between the first and third episodes
prompting NBC to cancel the show
mid-season showrunner Chad Hodge
confirmed that the Playboy club had four
completed episodes that remain unaired
despite the series costing NBC at least
2 million dollars an episode
friends is one of the biggest shows of
the 90s when it finally came to an end
in 2004 after 10 seasons it made perfect
sense that NBC would want to continue
its success in some way with a spin-off
the new series which made its debut near
the end of 2004 and was titled simply
Joey focused entirely on Matt leblanc's
character Joey Tribbiani who moves to
Hollywood to try and make it as a movie
actor the concept made sense but the
execution left a lot to be desired Kevin
bright one of the original friend's
producers believed that NBC had
disregarded his ideas for the spin-off
and made the show less fun than it
should have been ratings plummeted from
the first episode onward and NBC chose
to cancel the series Midway through its
season two although official figures
about the cost of making Joey have never
been detailed UK Channel 5 was paying as
much as 500 000 pounds for each episode
a staggering five times more than the
usual license fee meanwhile LeBlanc
claims that he earned 30 million dollars
for his role in the spin-off
based on the 2013 book The Good Girls
Revolt by Lynn Povich good girls revolts
tells the story of a group of female
writers at a news magazine who find
themselves subjected to absurd amounts
of sexism Genevieve angelson Anna camp
Aaron dark and tons of Parish for part
of the main cast and the show was
sometimes compared to the highly
acclaimed Mad Men by critics and fans
alike unfortunately the high quality
didn't translate into viewers with
Reuters revealing that only 1.6 million
tuned in with a budget in the region of
80 million dollars it is little wonder
that Amazon chose not to renew for
season two
a collaboration between Martin Scorsese
Terence Windsor and Mick Jagger vinyl is
a 2016 HBO series that focuses on the
music scene in New York during the 1970s
it was a taste of the population shift
from Rock to disco and Hip-hop music a
record company executive does his best
to stay relevant in the shifting
Marketplace Bobby carnavali
Otto asondo Jack Quaid and Ray romardo
had starring roles while scorsetti
himself executive produced and directed
The two-hour long pilot do you have any
idea how huge that is before episode 1
even hit TV screens HBO would have given
the green light for season two but the
network quickly reversed course only
months after the Show's first season
finale aired HBO confirmed that vinyl
had instead been canceled as it failed
to land costing 100 million dollars for
the first season that accounts to 10
million dollars per episode it was one
of HBO's most expensive projects but
also failed to find an audience and
manage less than a million viewers on
average scores however believes that the
series could have been more successful
if he had directed all the episodes and
devoted more time to it
despite plenty of criticism about his
final season Game of Thrones was such a
hit that HBO was always likely to
continue the franchise in some way fans
eventually got more Westeros with a
popular spin-off series House of the
Dragon but long before that another
project was in the works known by its
production named Blood Moon this show
was set to take place thousands of years
before the events of Game of Thrones HBO
officially green led to Pilot for the
series in 2018 and cast actors such as
Naomi Watson key roles with a budget of
30 million dollars the blood moon Pilot
cost more than the 50 million dollars
spent on each episode of the final
season of Game of Thrones meanwhile
deadline reported that there were long
delays and production issues throughout
the filming of the pilot including a
complete re-edit when HBO Executives
were unconvinced after seeing the first
cut HBO poured the plug shortly after
and locked the pilots away so that no
one would ever get to see it
[Music]
thank you